let me ask you perhaps a fun question
but there's a philosophy dude to will
there ever be a python 4.0 now before
you say it's currently a joke and
probably not I'm gonna go to 3.99 or
3.99 999.
can you imagine possible features
that python 4.0 might have that would
and necessitate the creation of the new
4.0 given the amount of
pain and joy suffering and Triumph that
was involved in the move between version
2 and version three
yeah well we're we
as a community and as a core development
team we have a large amount of painful
memories about the Python 3 transition
uh which is one reason that sort of
everybody is happy that we've decided
there's not going to be a 4.0 at least
not anytime soon and if there is going
to be one with the we'll sort of plan
the transition very differently because
clearly we underestimated the pain the
transition
cost for our users in the Python 3 case
and
had we known we could have sort of
designed Python 3 somewhat differently
without making it any worse
we just thought that we had a good plan
but we we we underestimated where
what what sort of the users were capable
of when it comes to that kind of
transition by the way I think we talked
way before like a year and a half before
the uh python 2 officially
end of life end of life oh yeah
what was that what was your memory of
the end of life did you shed a tear on
January 1st 2020 did was there
everyone's standing alone poor team had
basically moved on years before
yeah it was it was purely it was a
little symbolic moment
uh to signal to the the remaining users
that
there was no longer going to be any new
releases or support for python 2 7.
did you shed a single tier while looking
out over the horizon
I'm not not a very poetic person and I
don't shed tears like that but no
you know we we actually had planned a
party but the party was planned for uh
the python the U.S python conference
that year which would never happened of
course because of the pandemic oh was it
like in March yeah the conference was uh
going to be I think late April that year
oh
so that that was a very difficult
decision to cancel it but
they did so anyway if we're going to
have a python 4 we're going to have to
have both a different reason for for
having that
and a different process for managing the
transition can you imagine a possible
process that so so I think you're
implying that if there is a 4.0 in some
ways it would break back compatibility
well so
here is here is a concrete thought I've
had and I'm not unique but not everyone
agrees with this so this is definitely a
personal opinion
if we were to try something like that no
Guild python
uh
my expectation is that
it would feel
just different enough
at least for the the part of the Python
ecosystem that
is heavily based on C extensions
and that is like the entire machine
learning data science Scientific Python
world is all based on C extensions for
python
and so
those people would likely feel the pain
the most
because they even if we don't change
anything about the syntax of the
language and the semantics of the
language when you're writing python code
we we could even say suppose that after
python say 319 instead of 320 we'll have
4.0 suppose that's the time when we
flip the switch to 4.0 will will not
have a gill
imagine it was like that
so
I would probably say
that particular year the release that we
named 4.0 will be syntactically it will
not have any new syntactical features no
new modules in the standard Library no
new built-in functions
everything will be at the python level
will be purely compatible with python
3.19
however
extension modules
will have to make a change they all have
to be recompiled they will not have the
same
binary interface
uh
the semantics and and apis for for some
things that are frequently accessed by C
extensions will be different and so for
a pure python user
4.0 would be a breeze except that there
are very few pure python users left
because everybody who is using python
for something significant is using
third-party extensions they're like I
don't know several hundreds of thousands
of third-party extensions on the Pi Pi
service
and I'm not saying they're old they're
all good but there is a large list of
extensions that would have to do work
and some of those extensions are
currently already low on maintainers and
they're struggling to keep afloat so
there you can give a huge heads up to
them if you go to 4.0 to really keep
developing it yeah we'd probably have to
do something like
several years before who knows maybe
five years earlier like 3.15 we would
have to say and and I'm just making the
the specific numbers up but we at some
point we'd have to say foreign
python could be an option
it might be a compile time option
uh
if you want to use no Guild python you
have to recompile python from source for
your platform using your tool set
all you have to do is change one
configuration variable and then you just
run make
or configure and make and it will build
it for you
but now you also have to use the the
no-gill compatible versions of all
extension modules you want to use
and so as long as many extension modules
don't have fully functional
sort of variants that work within the
no-gill world
that's not a very practical thing for
python users but it would allow
extension Developers
to test the waters see what they need to
syntactically to be able to compile at
all maybe they're using
functions that are defined by the Python
3 runtime that won't be in the python 4
runtime those functions will not work
they'll have to find an alternative
uh but they can experiment with that and
sort of write test applications and that
would be a way to transition and that
that could be a series of releases where
the python 4 is more and more imminent
uh we have supported more and more
third-party extension modules to have
solid support that works for no Guild
python for that new API
uh and then sort of python python 4.0 is
like the official moment that the mayor
comes out and cuts the ribbon and is now
a python uh now the sort of no-gill mode
is the default and maybe the only mode
there is